okay good morning so um today we are
doing the Holy Roman Empire now last
class we did The bantin Empire which is
considered the
continuation of the Roman Empire in
Eastern Europe the Holy Roman Empire is
considered the
continuation of the Roman Empire in
Western
Europe so the um when we think about the
Holy Roman Empire in the west we think
of the famous voler uh quotation about
the Holy Roman Empire voler is um a very
famous French Enlightenment thinker we
will talk about voler when we get to the
Enlightenment what he said was the Holy
Roman Empire was in no way holy nor
Roman nor an Empire and this sounds
funny um and a lot of historians thought
it was a joke but what I will show you
this class is actually this is very true
okay so um the Holy Roman Empire was
started in the year
800 um when the Frankish King
Charlamagne was crowned Holy Roman
Emperor by Pope Leo theii in
Rome okay and this marked a turning
point
in Western history because this was
really the first
time that the pope could anoint a
monarch before it was the Emperor who
anointed the pope now it's a bit
reversed and this shows the supremacy of
the Catholic
Church historians have debated for a
long time why shamain would agree to
such an
arrangement and so this is the topic we
we will examine uh this class what
motivates Shan to Agree to Agree to such
a deal and what gave the Catholic Church
sorry what gave the Catholic church so
so much power and Prestige that they
were allow that they had the power to
anoint Emperors okay so that's a topic
we are looking at today all right so
let's first look at Mo charlamagne's
motivations Charlamagne um his name
means Charles the great and he is of the
Frankish uh Empire
and he was able to unite most of Europe
um through major Innovations in the
military um so he was the first to
introduce the idea of armor knights
which became the standard military
Doctrine and practice in Europe for
centuries and the idea of the night
would also pave the way for feudalism in
Europe and these are topics we'll
discuss later on uh in the class okay in
the
semester um um what Charlamagne is most
celebrated for um is the fact that he
started something called the Carolian
Renaissance Carolian is the name of his
family and the Renaissance is this um
period of peace and prosperity in Europe
um and he's most famous for the building
of cathedrals he built 14 of them this
is the most famous it's called the Akin
Cathedral in Aken Germany you can guys
you can still go visit it okay it is
beautiful um the cathedrals of medieval
Europe are really the pyramids like the
pyramids they are meant to give people a
sense of awe and
unity uh the cathedral was meant to
bring Heaven
onto uh
Earth one really amazing aspect about
the cathedral are the Acoustics the
sounds within uh the buildings it is
designed in a way that when the priest
speaks his voice is projected all around
the cathedral and the walls bounce the
um voice back and so the parishioners
the people who listen to the priest they
feel they're surrounded by the voice of
God okay the V the The Voice literally
enters you and makes you feel
Transcendent it makes you feel you are
moving towards heaven that you're
approaching God all right and these
buildings are still around so you can
actually go and uh visit them this is a
picture of modern day uh AK in Germany
where people go where tourists go and
visit the
cathedral okay so these buildings were
designed to be
Eternal Okay so so um before I talk
about Charlamagne and why he chose to be
Crown Holy Roman Emperor I need to give
you a little bit background about the
geography of Europe now if we if we look
at the um four major civilization
empires of early human history uh mainly
Egypt Mesopotamia in this Valley in
China we will discover that there are
three major similarities
among all four okay the first as you can
see from this picture is Du
latitudinally okay they are in the same
place they all benefit from temperate
climate which allows for year-long
agriculture that's the first major
similarity the second major similarity
is these are all River civilizations
meaning that at the center is a major
river surrounded by flat lands that
allows for the production of
Agriculture all right so in Egypt
there's a Nile Mesopotamia there are two
rivers the Tigers and Euphrates in this
Valley Civilization is obviously In this
River and in China there are two rivers
right there's the Yellow River and then
there's the uh yangi okay the Chang Jang
all right and the third major
characteristic uh that's very important
is they're surrounded by natural
boundaries whether it's mountains or
deserts or or oceans or Seas okay and
from this map you can see very clearly
uh these three three characteristics for
Egypt right Egypt has the Nile
surrounded by natural boundaries the
desert the Sahara Desert to the West
these
mountains um then protect uh Egypt and
that's what allows Unity to take hold
very quickly in the
civilizations and what allows uh this
civilization
to defend against outside Invaders okay
the same is true in China obviously
right
okay um surrounded by mountains to the
South to the west and to the North and
then the sea okay so for most of of its
history China was protected from outside
Invaders this is all especially true in
Humanity's greatest Empire called the
United stat States all right so if you
look at the United States it is a
fortress basically it's protected by two
oceans and then mountains but when
within the United States it's serviced
by the Mississippi River which allows
for agricultural Surplus and which
allows for trade and communication
within the United States so very early
on the United States could become very
wealthy as well as
unified and it didn't to fear external
enemies and therefore it could Prosper
without woring too much about um its
National
Defense okay this is very important
because none of these three things are
true for the European continent okay
especially Western Europe um it's much
too uh uh north um and it's surrounded
by lots and lots of mountains it also
has no major
rivers okay so as you can see from this
map in southern uh Western Europe it's
mainly mountains and to the north there
are um flat lands but they're usually
covered by
Forest okay so for most of its history
Europe was divided and poor and um
isolated from the rest of the world
okay the other thing about
Europe that made it distinct from the
other civilizations is within Europe
there are lots of natural boundaries and
that's why Europe remained divided for
such a long time it was extremely hard
to unite Europe please remember the Rome
was not a European Empire it was a
Mediterranean Empire that's a huge
difference okay so throughout most of
its history Europe was divided into
different Thoms and the prin the
princess the Kings had complete
authority over their
Kingdom and it was very hard to compel
them
to um listen to your Authority
Charlamagne had at at at that time the
greatest army in Europe but even then he
was still compelled to uh
cooperate with the other kings okay so
he achieved a lot of what he did through
Conquest but he also achieved a lot of
what he did through alliances and
treaties and friendships and marriages
okay so what this means is if you want
to UniFi Europe you cannot do so through
military conquest you have to do do so
through the idea of legitimacy
people have to believe you are the
legitimate
ruler you cannot compel them you must
win their hearts and
Minds okay and this explains why
Charlamagne would want to be crowned by
the pope because the pope did have
legitimacy he did have authority because
the pope was the leader of the Catholic
church and at this time there were many
kings not all of them but there were
many kings in Europe who were off the
Catholic faith
okay um so this is a map of the major
cities of the world at the time of the
fall of the Roman Empire okay as you can
see most of the cities are located at a
certain latitude and to the north okay
which is where Europe is there are not
that many major
cities right so at the fall of the Roman
Empire Europe was a divided weak and
poor
place
okay all right so again the please
remember for the rest of semester these
three factors right latitude you need a
temporate climate you need um natural
boundaries and you need a major river
and this will this is what allowed
civilizations to rise and prosper they
great irony of the great irony here of
course and we will learn about this um
later on the semester is despite its
disadvantages Europe was still able to
conquer the
world all right and it did so because of
these disadvantages if you think about
it these disadvantages compel you as a
people as a culture to be Innovative to
overcome these
disadvantages all right and this is
something that we will learn when we get
to the enlightenment Renaissance and
Sonic Revolution which we'll do very
quickly all
right um the other thing about Europe
that's very important is um it was
constantly being invaded look if you
look at this map you will see that there
are a lot of mountains protecting Egypt
Mesopotamia um and in this Valley in
China but there are almost none
protecting Europe from the
steps and as we discussed last semester
the steps traditionally has been the
most
aggressive place um in human history
people are always fighting each other
for territory these are pastoral people
who need land to raise their uh sheep
and cattle and so they're always
fighting each other and so what happens
over time is these people are pushed
further out into the uh Borderlands okay
they often pushed into into Europe right
so remember about the Y people how they
migrated from the steps to Europe and
basically conquered all of Europe well
this process never really
stops okay so um in the time of the
Roman Empire towards the claps of the
Western Roman Empire there's huge
migrations of people from the steps into
Europe and they're being pushed out by a
new more aggressive people called the
Huns okay you may have heard of Atilla
the Hun well he's all that group and
they are extremely violent and they have
made M major military innovations that
allow them to out compete others in the
steps which forc these other tribes and
groups
into uh Europe okay which is the only
place they can
go all
right um after the claps of the Roman
Empire
um these different groups start to form
their own
kingdoms around Germany are the Franks
and then eventually over
time um as these groups compete against
each other the Franks will ultimately
defeat them and expand okay but this is
a process that will take centuries
through multiple Kings and through
multiple dynasties but
eventually um the the Franks will expand
out from Germany and Conquer most of
Europe not all of Europe they will
conquer uh most of Europe and in the
process what's interesting for us is
they will make contact with the once
isolated um Scandinavian
countries um the the the Norsemen okay
they're called the Norse we we often
refer them to as Vikings and we will
study them next class okay but now
they're bought brought into the OR bit
of this new Frankish Empire okay but
again and and this is the Frankish
Empire at the time of Charlamagne when
he creates the Holy Roman Empire but
again because this is not really an
Empire it's more of a confederation it
doesn't really last much longer after
his death what's really interesting for
us is to remember that these emperors
they are not born as Emperor they are
elected by other kings so again you
should see this as an alliance as
Confederacy where each King has voting
power okay so this is not a her title
this is something that you are elected
to okay so after the death of
Charlamagne um a couple decades later
after his death the Empire splits into
three
okay and even though um on paper this
Empire does last until the year 1806
it's a history uh that is extremely
tumultuous and most and there are some
times when the Empire completely
disintegrates okay but they keep up the
pretense of having an Empire because
again in Egypt what matters is not
territory or military or resources what
matters the most is legitimacy and the
idea of the Holy Roman Empire gives uh
legitimacy confers legitimacy mainly
through the Catholic Church okay does
that make sense guys so we'll be
discussing more of this as we go um into
the history of
Europe but before that are there any
questions sorry uh are there any
questions all right so now what I want
to discuss is why the Catholic church is
able to confer legitimacy
what gives the Catholic Church the
power and authority to confer legitimacy
uh to Kings and Emperors okay but before
I do that um are you guys clear about
what I just
presented mention
that Pope Leo thei
yes oh well sorry okay so I I'll explain
okay but the pope is considered the
leader of the church in Rome so so he's
a bishop okay we call him Pope because
historically Rome was most powerful of
all the
churches okay so so so so I'll explain
who the pope is later on okay so but
does that make sense good any more
questions before I continue because
right now what I'll do is explain how
the Catholic Church became so powerful
in Europe
okay that's a good question okay so um
who are who are these Kings well most of
these kings are
actually uh hereditary okay their
fathers were Kings their grandfathers
were Kings and they often related to
each other okay but they were control of
a certain
Thom right and you couldn't really
conquer them because they had castles
and they had and they were like in
mountains and they were a very
aggressive people so you couldn't really
coner them so you needed
to um get them to to agree to make you
King and so the way they did that was by
having these elections where the Kings
got together they call Prince electors
and they p take the the king and this is
also true for the Catholic Church where
different Bishops would get together and
they would elect the pope okay but but
I'll explain this later on okay does
that make sense all right
okay all right so um let's go over the
history of the Catholic church and
explain understand why it became so
powerful in Europe after the collapse of
the Roman Empire
okay first I want to present to you the
official history of the Catholic Church
as presented by the Catholic church so
um there was
a man named Jesus who was actually a God
we we didn't know he was a God but he
was a God who came down from heaven in
order to sacrifice himself in order to
free us of our sins to in order to
redeem us okay now Jesus had disciples
there were there were 12 major ones but
there were others and after his death
Jesus reappeared before
them and told them to spread the gospel
the good
news that he has freed Humanity of their
sins and that he will return to create a
heaven on Earth okay so that's a good
news the gospel so these disciples
they're illiterate peasants they go all
around the world and they set up
churches in the honor of Jesus okay the
these are the first fathers of the
church and these people are called
Bishops okay so the bishop is the head
of the church in a certain
area and the tradition is that the very
first Bishop of all the major churches
and they were like five um were
Disciples of Jesus that's where their
Authority and legitimacy comes from from
Jesus
himself um as the movement is spreading
Rome sees them as a threat because Rome
are pagans and Christianity is an
anti-pagan religion so um there's a lot
of persecution going on but
the Christians are armored by their
faith and their love of Jesus and the
miracle that is God so they eventually
Triumph and convert all of Rome into
Christianity now Christianity is the
official religion of Rome and now they
have the power to spread the message to
all people around the world but
especially the barbarians of Europe and
convert them okay so that's the official
history
of the church and there are lots and
lots of issues with this story I mean
the first uh issue the major issue is
how is is it that a peasant religion was
able to conquer the Roman
Empire
um there are certainly other belief
systems that were much more compelling
than the Christian faith there's a Greek
system the philosophy of Plato um Pagan
paganism itself has many traditions and
as I keep on explain to you in this
class culture is persistent people do
not want to change their cultures so
it's a complete mystery how Christianity
was able to spread and Conquer Europe
and the explanation if you talk to
Christians especially the Catholic
church is it's a miracle guys it's a
power of Faith okay that's the
explanation that's it
um okay so there are lots of issues with
this official story so I want to give
you my understanding of the history I
talked about this last semester and I
want to review it okay and apply to the
context of the Roman Empire all
right what's important for us to
understand is during the time of the
Roman Empire the Romans had major
conflicts with the
provincials especially the Jews okay
Romans and Jews did not get
along in fact they were often in
conflict with each
other the Romans were Pagan and the Jews
were monotheistic people who only
worship
Yahweh and they refused to worship the
Roman Emperor which was demanded of them
by the Romans sometimes the Romans were
tolerance says well we'll make a special
exception for you Jews but some they
were extremely violent okay and this led
to a series of Wars uh in Judea between
the Jews and the Romans these were
terrible terrible Wars that killed
millions of people okay three major wars
were fought another problem is that the
Jews were spread all around the Roman
Empire so this is not a problem isolated
to one poor
Province called Judea this was a problem
throughout the Roman Empire okay so um
historians estimate that Jews accounted
for about 10% of the population of the
Roman Empire that's a lot of people and
certain cities like
Alexandria um it was a third of the
population and there were a couple riots
in in alandria by the Jews against Roman
rule also the Jews were at as a whole a
pretty
Cosmopolitan people who are well
educated uh and who are very well
established who look down upon the
Romans the Jews had respect for the
Greeks because the Greeks had a very uh
Superior culture Jews and Persians got
along really well because Persians are
extremely tant people but Jews really
didn't like Romans and the Romans really
didn't like the Jews either okay there
there's stories of how after the wars uh
between the Romans and the Jews Jews
were enslaved and sent to Rome and the
Romans released the Jews from slavery
because they didn't like Jews okay and
Jews became traitors and set settle um
in other parts of of of the Empire okay
so the Romans and the Jews didn't get
along and so there's this constant
conflict going
on but there are certain Jews Like Paul
of Tarsus he was a Roman citizen he was
very well established within the
Empire and he got along very well with
the Romans he really much want to be
part of the Roman Empire and these wars
were badly affecting him and his and his
family and and their friends okay so
there were a certain segment of the of
the Jewish diaspora who very much wanted
to assimilate
into um Roman into the Roman Empire but
their religion okay their religion which
believ that eventually mesiah who is a
prince from the House of David born of
the House of David he will return and he
will lead the Jews to Ultimate Victory
against the Romans that's that's what
the Jews believe as part of their
religion and so this present a problem
for Paul of Tarsus and other Jews want
to
assimilate
okay when Jesus
died he became like a rock star within
the Jewish
community
and the fact that he died the way that
the fact that he was crucified which is
which is a horrible way to die um it
basically captur the imagination of many
Jews and after his death there were a
lot of people who started to flock to uh
they were very curious about him um so
they flocked to uh his disciples and so
um his brother
James LED his movement called the poor
of Jerusalem later on they'll be called
the aites okay and these are the people
who will influence
the Islamic religion but there were
other groups who started around Jes
around the idea of Jesus as well okay so
Jesus was a growing popularity um in the
Jewish world after his death and in
Jesus Paul saw an opportunity to resolve
this conflict between Romans and
Jews remember the problem for Jews is
the religion believed that a messiah
would return who would lead them to
Victory against the
Romans and this is a
problem uh because Paul knew that if the
Jews United against the Romans the
Romans will probably win okay so to
Jesus is a solution because Jesus is a
prophet of peace right Jesus
was a prophet who preached the
importance of Peace mercy and
forgiveness forgive the Romans for
destroying our Temple forgive the Romans
for persecuting us show Mercy because
What mattered is not what happens here
what happen what matters is what happens
in Heaven All right
so Paul of Tarsus backed by the Roman
State start this
religion as a way for Jews to practice
their faith without incurring the Wrath
of the Roman Empire without being a
threat to the Roman Empire okay does
that make sense do you guys now over
time as the conflict between the Romans
and Jews became worse and worse the
Christian Movement spread okay and
eventually to gain legitimacy they won
the patronage of Roman uh Patriarchs
okay so uh you had a certain segment of
elite Jews and a certain segment of
elite Romans who came together in the
Christian
church uh to build an
alliance and okay does that make sense
so in other words um the Catholic Church
the beginning of Catholic Church it was
basically basically an elite social club
for Jews and Romans to get together and
to work together okay does that make
sense now what's important for us to
understand is there are other Christian
factions during this time but because
the Catholic Church the beginning the
protoc Catholic church it's backed by
the Roman State and because of its
organization its wealth it was able to
ultimately win out over the other
Christian sects okay does that make
sense all right now over
time what the Romans recognize is wow
the Christian church is great at solving
the Jewish
problem and then they recognize that oh
wouldn't be good for solving all
our problems okay because because
eventually um the Jews cease to be the
major problem and Le Barbarian bar Ians
coming in from the steps and from the
north are the major problem and there's
just too many of
them okay so remember you have all
these um barbarians coming in what's
important to remember up these
barbarians is this is not an invasion
okay an
invasion often historians will use the
word barbarian
Invasion they're not Invaders they're
migrants it's a migration
guys what's the difference well if if
it's an invasion these people are
looking to conquer the Roman Empire and
instill upon the Empire their worldview
their culture their religion if it's a
migration these people are looking for
better economic
opportunities and therefore they are
willing to conform to your worldview to
your religion
all right so think about the United
States where on the southern border
there are millions of people every year
who are trying to get into United States
they're not there to conquer the United
States they're there to Mig the United
States and seek a better life and they
know that if they are to succeed in
United States they must
assimilate okay and the best way to
assimilate United States of course is to
go to university
right because once you're part of the
University you're now part of the social
Elite okay that's the best thing to do
but a lot of people don't have the
wealth the education to go to university
so what what they often do is join the
church okay the
church um if you look at these hundred
of thousands these millions of Chinese
students who have on United States the
group that has assimilated the best are
Chinese Christians
right these are um Chinese who are
either practicing Christians or they
convert to Christianity when they go
United States because when they when
they're Christians there's an immediate
social Community for them that welcomes
them and supports them okay does not
makes sense guys all right so
um this United stes days but this was
too during the late Roman Empire as well
okay the you have all these barbarians
they're called barbarians and they're
coming
in and they're trying to assimilate and
the Roman Empire needs to assimilate
them as well and what they discovered is
the best way to do that is through the
Catholic
church right because remember these P
these C these barbarians they are pagans
they worship War they worship violence
they're a problem in the long term but
they convert to Christianity which is a
religion that preaches peace Mercy
forgiveness
kindness right then they're better then
they're easier to
manage and what happens is that um a lot
do convert okay now some of you may say
well this sounds very
cynical right these people are changing
their
religion and they're doing so for their
own material benefit okay what's
important for us to understand is that
if you look at any religion if you go to
any church you will find that the people
who most believe in this religion who
are the most fanatical about this
religion are new converts does that make
sense if you're bornn into this religion
if your parents are Christians you take
it for
granted okay and you are often dubious
and skeptical because children like to
rebel against their parents but if you
convert to Christianity if you do so out
out of your own
choice well then
you are fully committed now okay and
this is because of a psychological
principle called the
sunk cost
fallacy to turn to a new religion means
to give up your community your
Traditions your history your sense of
identity and because because of all this
you are stuck with this new religion
whether or not you truly believe it or
not and as and because of that because
of the sun Claus fallacy uh because you
have you have lost so much in the
process you are now fully committed to
the religion you're are so fanatical
that you not only convert but you want
to convert others as well okay does that
make sense so so with the Barbarian
invasions the Catholic Church
experiences tremendous growth because
now they are letting in lots of converts
who are fanatical about the new
religion all
right the church is also a mechanism of
social
nobility um for The Barbarians because
uh Roman society it's very uh
parochial uh it's very close-minded it
doesn't like does not like does not like
foreigners okay but traditionally in
human history The Church and the
military were the two major mechanisms
of social Mobility if you're an outsider
and you want to rise in society you
either join the church or you join a
military and this and this has been true
for uh in Europe for hundreds of years
okay the last thing about the church
that's very important is
um in trying to co-op new people it
recognizes that it must first Co-op the
elite okay now barbarians do not they do
not have or most barbarians do not have
a concept of a hereditary Elite their
leaders are often people who are elect
for the
moment okay so it's possible to switch
leaders if the leaders aren't performing
a good
job what the church does is in exchange
for Jing the CH the the church the
church can make these leaders who again
are only temporary into a hereditary
Elite meaning their advantages and
social status will pass on to their
children which is an
extremely um
appealing um
deal for these Barbarian leaders okay
does that make
sense all right
so as The Barbarians keep on migrating
to Rome the Catholic church is the main
mechanism that absorbs them okay also
the military as well so it's a military
in the Church of the Roman Empire that
mainly absorbs
them and this and because of this idea
the church is a mechanism which allows
you to join the Roman
Empire the church acquires tremendous
legitimacy and Prestige and
Status okay does that make sense for you
guys all
right all
right but in this
system okay local churches have local
autonomy because you're trying to let in
local Elites okay if you land in local
Elites you have to give them
autonomy and um towards the end of the
uh Roman Empire there are five major
churches that rule
collectively uh the major church is in
Rome okay again the
leaders um all these churches are called
Bishops there's Rome there's constant
aole there is
um
Antioch there's
Alexandria and these are the four major
population centers of the Roman Empire
and then of course there is Jerusalem
and Jerusalem is is part of this five
because of
its uh Prestige right this is where
Jesus uh died and this is the this is
where the uh Jewish and Christian
religions were born okay so um
throughout most of of this history these
are the five major churches and for most
of this history they are independent of
each other there are other churches in
other places as well that are also
extremely independent of each other
meaning they were allowed to within the
Christian framework develop their own
Doctrine and
practices okay but it was
understood the uh primary church was
Rome because Rome was a second Center
the capital of the Roman Empire and
because of this the bishop here is
called the Pope in order to distinguish
him from the other Bishops okay does
that make
sense all right the problem with the
system is that the capital in 330
switches from Rome over to constant and
over time the constant church because it
is now the capital it wants to assert
its authority over the other churches
mainly through the idea of Orthodoxy
right Orthodoxy or
doctrine remember for most of this
history each local church is free to um
create its own ideology within the
Christian framework mainly because um no
one's in a position to enforce Doctrine
on others now Conant Paul want because
it's a capital of the Empire it wants to
impose Orthodoxy on others and this is
what leads to the idea of the nine creed
remember the nine creed is the idea of
the Holy
Trinity and at this time when the nine
creed is for
formulated um most people most churches
do not buy into the thean Creed they
don't they do not buy into the Holy
Trinity but Conant Paul sees the Power
of the Catholic Church
as a source of its legitimacy therefore
it will over the decades embark on
Military expeditions to enforce nine
creed on all the centers eventually the
nine creed will triumph over other
Doctrine okay so uh the Catholic
church is able to build legitimacy and
Power by imposing
Orthodoxy but over time as we know the B
bis Empire will
decline in power and Prestige mainly
because the bantine Empire the
militarily is not as strong as it used
to be and at this point the Cal church
is declining other churches especially
in Rome they want now to assert their
local
autonomy okay so this created a major
controversy called iconic clasm iconic
clasm ionm just means that conapo
believes that God should not be
celebrated in images you cannot paint
God you cannot uh paint
Jesus
okay and the church in Rome the pope saw
this as an opportunity to push back
because this was actually a very
unpopular decree and this created a
major conflict between Rome and
constantinopole and what this ionm
debate shows us is that Rome wants
to maintain its
independence not only does Rome want to
maintain its independence it wants to
regain its lost
Authority okay and that's why when
Charlamagne comes
along the church sees Charlamagne as the
perfect opportunity to reassert its
dominance it's it's uh dominance over
the idea of legitimacy okay right and so
they work together to create the idea of
the Holy Roman
Empire as a
competitor to the bantine Empire as and
as a mechanism in order to ensure the
legitimacy and The Prestige of the
Catholic church in Rome against that of
its competing churches mainly in conle
but also in plac like alandre an in
Jerusalem all right and this will
eventually climax in something called
the great
schism the great
schism we'll study this later on the
idea of the great schism which happens
around 1,000 all right is that that
these two churches Rome and Conant pople
permanently break off they refuse to
acknowledge each other before they would
have meetings and they would share
Doctrine but now they absolutely refuse
to talk to each other okay Rome will
become the basis of the Catholic Church
Catholic means
Universal which still is still around
today and which is believed by about one
billion people okay heno becomes the
basis of the Eastern Orthodox Church the
Eastern Orthodox Church which is um
believed by about 230 million people
mainly in Eastern Europe okay so if
you're Western Europe you're Catholic if
sorry if you're East Eastern Europe
you're Orthodox if you're Western Europe
you're Catholic okay does that make
sense guys and at first look there's
only one major doct doctrinal difference
between Rome and constant pop Rome
asserts that the pope is the first among
equals okay so the pope is has the
ultimate Authority the pope is a two
representative of God on Earth everyone
else is lesser than the pope whereas uh
the Orthodox Church asserts that all the
churches are equal to each other there
is no higher
authority okay but later on because the
um the church in Rome will experience
the Protestant
Reformation
um then their Doctrine will radically um
diverge over time okay does it make
sense
all
right any questions about
this okay so let's summarize okay let's
go back to the year 800 when Charlamagne
he's in St Peter's
Basilica and he's been
crowned holy woman Empire by Leo III why
does this happen Okay and let's look at
at it from a perspective of charlot mean
as well as Pope
Leo
III all
right so for schler M it's p the three
major
reasons are
legitimacy
unity and
differentiation and this has been true
for Kings
throughout human history okay
why did King David sponsor the writing
of the Bible for these three reasons why
did Augustus Caesar sponsor the writing
of the indiat for these three reasons
okay legitimacy I'm the rightful King
because God said so Unity where we're
all part of the community of
God okay and that's what differenes
differenti we are Christians and
everyone else is Pagan or Infidel or
heretic differentiation we are not not
the bantine Empire okay so
Charlamagne is trying to create
legitimacy unity and
differentiation with the Holy Roman
Empire
okay
so Pope
Leo why does
[Music]
he um sponsor shamine why is he crying
shamine the whole Roman Empire well um
he's trying to Asser his authority right
he's trying to establish the fact that
the pope is a true representative of God
on on
Earth okay second is he's trying to um
protect himself so you guys don't know
this
but in this
world there's no Central Power
and the pope is elected by other Bishops
but in this process you always have a
faction who refuses to accept the
authority of the Pope and this will lead
to civil conflict so before Pope
Leo uh made charag Emperor he was Al
almost assassinated by his
enemies right so by making
um uh charine the Holy Roman Emperor
he's actually appealing to shamain for
military protection against his enemies
okay so there's a lot of um politics
within the Catholic Church which still
persists to uh
today okay and of
course um differentiation okay or
competition sorry competition the idea
is that the Catholic church is in
constant compet the Catholic church in
Rome is in constant comp conflict with
that in
bantine both the bisan Empire um and the
Catholic church in Rome are trying to
assert that they are the
legitimate heers to the Roman
Empire okay and obviously bising has a
better case than Rome and that's why
Pope Leo feels compelled to create the
idea of the Holy Roman uh
Empire all right what I want to show you
also that the
idea of the Holy Roman Empire comes
from
Augustine okay one thing that you will
learn in this
class that's very different from other
um class his history class you will take
it's a power of
ideas you're taught usually that it's
economics or power or kings that move
history
you're Tau in this class and this is
very important it's it's ideas that move
history okay let let me show you how
Okay Augustine wrote a book called city
of God which is what we
read last semester or parts of it last
semester we discussed it okay what a
city of God well Augustine he's
basically um a high leader of the church
he's Bishop of Hippo okay which is in
Northern Africa and he's a problem
because in year
410 Rome is
sacked okay there only a few couple a
couple decades after Christianity is
made the official religion of the Roman
Empire now Rome is sacked by the gos by
by barbarians who are pagans and so what
a lot of people start to believe is that
the pagan gods
are um enacting Revenge vengeance
against Rome for disbaling them in other
words the Christian God is the false god
the pagan gods are the true gods and
this historical event where Rome is
sacked um it's so traumatizing that
people start to believe this so
Augustine feels compelled to write the
city of God to explain the sack and why
Christianity is a true faith in the city
of God Augustine says there are two
there are two cities there's a city of
man of Empire called
Rome Rome is a place where people pursue
power where Kings try to uh outdo each
other then then there Jerusalem okay
Jerusalem which is the city of God this
is metaphorical Rome is temporal it is
in time it is off Earth but Jerusalem is
heaven itself and in heaven it's a
spiritual place where people practice
their faith their Devotion to God and
that is what we should be
pursuing okay so Rome is trying to
create the end of
History meaning that it is trying to
create an eternal peace right what it's
called the Pax
Romana the Emperors are trying to be the
ultimate emperor of humanity but
Jerusalem means out of
History you are taking yourself out of
human Affairs because the human Affairs
don't really matter what matters is
spiritual Faith because only spiritual
faith will will give you salvation and
Redemption and that's what
matters okay so our mission is to create
Jerusalem and that's what the Catholic
Church does the Catholic church is the
city of God
it's the New Jerusalem it's what allows
Humanity to step out of history and to
celebrate God on Earth okay and the City
of God in other words becomes the
basis of the Holy Roman
Empire in other words
Charlamagne and Leo work together work
together to create the Holy Roman
Empire in order to achieve Austin's
vision
of Heaven on Earth the city of God was
it's intellectual blueprint for the Holy
Roman Empire okay does that make sense
guys in fact what's really interesting
is
Charlamagne who apparently was
illiterate I'm not completely sure but
apparently he was illiterate every day
he had the city of God read to him
that's how much he love city of God and
he basically made city of God the
official text of the Holy Roman
Empire okay does it make sense and
that's a power of ideas Charlemagne in
the city of God had already created
theal framework for the Holy Roman
Empire that 4 4 400 years later Leo and
Shan could take to in order to build the
Holy Roman Empire but the city of God
they could not have imagined the Holy
Roman Empire okay does that make sense
guys that's power of ideas you need
someone to imagine the idea before you
can actually implement it on
Earth all right so let me conclude by
going back to Volt's quotation that we
looked at at the beginning of class the
Holy Roman Empire was in no way Holy
Roman or an Empire and as I promise you
um I will show you that this is true
okay so let's look at this holy
Roman
Empire the idea of
holy is that the Catholic church is
really the power in charge but that's
just pageantry that's a fiction okay the
entire holy romanempire it's a useful
fiction okay
so the king and the
pope uh are benefit from pretending the
Catholic church is in charge in order to
confer legitimacy onto the
king okay and the king and the pop
benefit from
displaying um an alliance to the people
of Europe okay to create a sense of
unity but this fiction
depends on the pope and the emperor
getting along and after Charlemagne what
we'll see is they don't get along
because a pope insists on having power
over the emperor the emperor insists on
having power over the pope but not only
that remember the
pope and the emperor are all elected by
local Lords okay so the pope is in is
elected by the Bishops of Western Europe
the emperor is is elected by the prince
electors and these people are also
extremely ambitious they want to be the
pope they want to be the emperor okay so
with the idea with the idea of the Holy
Roman Empire there's still conflict
going on there's still Wars and
competition going on that will last for
centuries and carry us into um basically
20th century but it all goes underground
they all hide it pretend that Europe is
at peace when really um It's At War okay
and some of the
most
atrocious gruesome stories will come
from this this medieval period it's a
game of throne situation okay so it's
not holy the church everyone pretends
the church is in charge but it's not
really okay
Roman so the authority of the Catholic
Church comes from the fact that it is
the direct descendant of the Roman
Empire in fact the Catholic Church uh
goes out of its way to appear like the
Roman
Empire um Latin is the language that the
Catholic Church uses for
bureaucracy and a lot of um their
practices cultural practices are like
the Roman okay um remember that in the
Roman Empire it's the Senate that
confers legitimacy onto the emperor and
in this world it's the Catholic church
that confers legitimacy onto the emperor
so the um Ro Catholic Church is trying
to present itself as continuation of the
Roman senate but as we discuss um in
previous classes what matters is the
culture and as I explained to you the
culture of the Romans died with the
Empire and and the death of this culture
started in the year 212
when Roman
CIP was given to everyone within the
Empire okay so the Roman Empire died a
long time ago the Catholic church is not
Roman native
Empire okay so the bises were an Empire
because they had emperial bureaucracy
and its own military that can enforce
its will on the
provinces the Holy Roman Empire was
never truly an empire in the sense that
the emperor's will was absolute he
needed uh the
support of his allies and there were
many times throughout this history when
the emperor tried to inforce his will on
the prince electors of Germany and so
they rebelled against him because they
need to protect his autonomy and this
idea that what matters um the real
Powers is uh in these princes in the
local areas this is what will give rise
to the idea of
feudalism uh in Europe okay okay
before um the Kings decide to assert
their authority over
everyone okay all right so the Holy
Roman Empire was a useful fiction for
its time in order to um present the idea
of legitimacy and
unity um across a
divided uh Europe at war with each
other right
okay so next class we will do the
Vikings all right but before we end any
questions
yes yes
um okay that's a really good question
okay what what's relationship of the
prince electors to the
emperor okay
um
so this is a really interesting question
okay so let's think about this if you
are Prince elector you are a local
Prince uh
um in Europe okay how do you benefit
from the Holy Roman Empire well you
benefit because the Holy Roman Empire
confers legitimacy to you as well does
that make
sense right because if you're local
Prince you also have people who want
your throne you also need to keep your
people United and the Catholic Church
the religion of Catholicism was an
important mechanism for you to assert
authority over your people and to keep
you safe from your
enemies in many ways the Catholic church
it's trying to be the freelance Imperial
bureaucracy of Europe right there's no
Emperor the emperor has no power so the
Catholic church is trying to be the
Imperial bureaucracy where he trying to
create the culture The Meta reality of
all Europeans okay and and it does that
through its local churches right the
priests because if you think about it um
the people are interacting with the
local priests not with
bureaucrats right so through the priest
you can collect information on the
people like how much money they're
making so you can tax them better and
you you can better control their
thoughts okay so everyone's benefiting
from this
relationship but it's a delicate B
because the local princes even even
though they're benefiting from this
relationship they still demand autonomy
right and the Catholic church and the
emperor they want to assert the central
authority over the local areas so so
it's a delicate
balance
right okay great question though doesn't
make sense to you EO all right great any
more questions
okay great so um next class we will do
the Vikings which will be a lot of fun